what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to a
fake college scout
prank youtube video this is especially
funny to me because i played
three sports in college i've always been
involved in sports
and i know how excited like people got
when the scouts would come on the court
so
um yeah this is just really funny to me
um before i start do not forget to
subscribe
to the channel bring that notification
bell
as you guys know i'm trying to hit 20
000 subscribers it's a big goal for the
channel
and if you bring the notification bell
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos
[Applause]
all right boys man so if you guys been
on the channel for a minute now you guys
will know that a while back we did this
fake college football scout prank right
would you say he's more of a von miller
or amir khalifa
louis my second choice mia khalifa was
an absolute banger and everything so
we're going to run it back real quick
but instead of doing college football
we're going to go out to an aau
tournament literally at these
tournaments there'll be ball is life
there there'll be all kind of college
scouts
flight reacts might be there anybody and
everybody could be there
so we're gonna be representing lsu and
just to be extra careful
i bought a lanyard and we're gonna
actually make security badges to make
sure we're like we look official man but
we gotta look like urban meyer sent us i
don't know
i don't know who's the college couch i
can't i don't even i don't know nothing
about college basketball but on the
right up there i'm gonna do my research
yeah we're about to take an id pick real
quick
[Music]
oh my god that's so funny
i appreciate the dedication when i i ran
security for a
concert once when i was an undergrad and
you'd be amazed if you just have the
right uniform what people will let you
do
all right boys we just got here right
now i'm not gonna lie i'm kind of dummy
nervous there's a lot of black people
here black
dads do not play this [ __ ] but i already
know this hoe's going to be a banger
chandler jones says so oh we're just
here with the priest scouts for the
house here
we're pre-scouting for lsu okay
thank you yeah i was wondering got the
lsu discount
oh what what college team do you got for
the discount
ole miss discount tsu discount
u of h discount total community college
discount
how you doing which one's yours out
there right here
tayden campbell jaden campbell what was
this neat plug
for real shoot in a point a boat
boat you know what the shooter
percentages
you're not sure what about his raw dog
percentage like that his raw dog
percentage like how many kills does he
be getting
how many like how many no kills
no he is not what do you mean like with
the girls at his high school
girls yeah i don't know
kills yeah like how many girls are these
fighting through the crib
oh no that you know of course right now
cap high schooler so he's in the boys
right now james charles
he's just having the girls right now
just kind of his books
i like how he doesn't smile at all like
he does not
so is it just that he doesn't have any
game or is it because you're [ __ ]
walking
because the boys that get the most kills
they'd be the ones that we want on our
team you know that means they're you
know
they can multitask they got 10 shotties
in their phone and they can still drop
20 on your head
nah that's what we need but hey once he
starts talking to the females and start
doing some side things
some of our way
why did he say all right
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
sebastian mackey man how tall are you
yeah cap you got a lot of harder here
what do you think about playing ball
though
like white girls we got the baddest
white girls in the cold country
i'm being for real it's no bunny look at
his face he does not know how to respond
he does not all day every day
you can handle all that they're big
bodies too you might have to take one
for the team
[Music]
[Applause]
look at you good game keep it up
[Music]
who's yours out there number two
oh really yeah so young yeah you know
the burdens
and uh we got him into a trainer now
starting to see some serious stuff out
of them
yeah get him on that spinach be on some
popeye [ __ ]
his verb will go from a 30 to a 69 real
quick
yeah i'm telling you people will believe
anything if you say it confidently
tell me bro that [ __ ] got me right you
got to get him on the spinach
[Applause]
and what number you said he was again
i'ma look out for number four
oh who's your son hey he said i'm gonna
look out for number four
here so does he start
not on distance because it's a 17-18
team and he's just a
sophomore also he's not starter
he's like bye look at that kid he knows
i never thought i was a bald head
brother here how you doing what's going
on man
challenge chandler jones
is he scoring twos or three is off the
court
like with the girls they'll be getting
the twos or get threes
i'm saying does he score twos or threes
off the court
off the court like with the girls are
they twos or are they threes
i don't know what you're talking about
like is he scoring lizzo's or summer
raised
bro you got the move on man you tripping
man tripping yeah
[Music]
oh my god that's so funny he's getting
so mad
let me enjoy this game man y'all enjoy
it move okay
i'm gonna go get my eliza real quick
no definitely you could you
it's all good you can score twos
[Applause]
[Music]
damn
he's starting a full ass
i know who you are
no no no no i'm chandler jones
he broke the camera bro he does not
break character
at all so uh can we go back in
look you came on the side of the court
with the clipboard acting like a coach
oh i'm not a coach i know but the way
you did it like
i don't know if this is for youtube
video or not which honestly i was
laughing it didn't have me laughing
chandler jones okay all right challenge
well you can't [ __ ] do that man
the reason he came down was because i
asked him if his son was scoring twos or
threes off the court
dude i saw him and then he got mad and
he was like yeah like i said i was
laughing man but and i was like lizzie's
like
look at this guy
oh my god the reactions are so funny
just got offended
that i brought it to light in front of
everybody that someone's messing with
lizzos
lsu pre-scholar department chandler
jones nice to meet you i'm brian jalapen
i'm the tournament director
nice to meet you i'm turning my director
i love how he does not break character
did how did you get in here did you pay
to get in here
oh no i got the special pass
there's no special pass the lady at the
interest she saw my d1 highlights and
she was like
it doesn't matter dude you guys gotta go
man you guys gotta go
we gotta do it yeah you gotta dip man
your [ __ ] bro
damn he broke the camera y'all now you
guys know
don't ask dads if their sons are messing
with twos or three
[Music]
oh my god that's like the funniest i
i am this guy's new biggest fan i swear
to god that is so
funny um let me know in the comments if
there's any other prank videos like that
i should react to next and do not forget
to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification bell i'll talk to you guys
next time